all right guys before you guys watch
this Vlog I have something huge to
announce literally right now like right
now right now like right now I'm working
on the barbell Brigade Black Friday sale
okay look I'm drawing it out on a piece
of paper because before it becomes a
nice website like this everything starts
janky like this don't make fun of me
that's how I like to do things that's
like how I like to communicate I like to
go with pen and paper but anyways the
big big sales that are going on Black
Friday starts November 24th on a
Thursday at 7 00 p.m you don't want to
miss out okay because all supplements
are buy one get one half off got it even
our best selling sour gumming
pre-workout yes our brown sugar Boba
protein yes our immunity support which
is our electrolyte and vitamin C blend
in Agua de Pina it's delicious pineapple
yes our performance greens with six
superfoods yes our apparel goes from 25
off to 50 off to 75 off okay on some
items which is crazy are mystery boxes
okay are 25 off all digital programs are
25 off so it's our biggest sale of the
year you don't want to miss out so make
sure you mark your calendars and uh
follow the bottle Brigade IG because
every single day will be announced it
will be will be announcing some of our
highest inventory items in a specific
size so like extra large is or Smalls or
mediums so that you guys know exactly
where to go to bum rush because I know a
lot of things have sold out really quick
this year and I want everyone to get
what they want so go to
bottlebrigade.com on uh I mean every day
but most importantly November 24th at 7
00 PM Pacific Standard Time good morning
guys I am extremely
stoked so I'm in one of my favorite
places in Vegas called tavoli Village
and reminds me of Florence Italy where
it's very renaissancey and it feels very
European and every time we've come here
we've stopped by this place called Leone
Cafe which is right behind me and the
line is out the Wazoo all the time so
this morning we're gonna try to get
breakfast I was like I'm a call because
we're kind of early and see what the
wait is like and I called them and
they're like the weight's only 10-15
minutes I was like okay cool we gotta
stop by one of the reasons why I'm so
excited about this place is it has such
a European like Italian specific vibe
that like you know that feeling where
you could just like walk up to a place
get a coffee sit outside enjoy like the
beautiful air and the Sun and stuff
that's what this place is all about so
when you come here all the seating is
first come first serve so you actually
go inside and Order what you want and
that's the sign if you guys are looking
for it the only Cafe and you could sit
anywhere you want on the outside
we got mama and papa not mama papa look
up mama over here you know what I called
you I called you papa your bikini
what I love about this place is you go
in here right and it has a very like
Italian Cafe deal so like look at even
at the marble floor as you can talk very
very big on decor and then that's the
menu up there so they have all these hot
beverages and one thing that caught my
eye was the Leone special record look at
that espresso milk honey and cinnamon I
was like oh never heard of that before
that sounds incredible and in here
reminds me of uh have you ever been to
Bodega Louie in L.A Vibe you come
outside and you can sit anywhere you
want and the boys is having like a happy
breakfast chilling talking I even love
that sign up there because that really
reminds me of Florence and everyone's
just having a good time outdoors in the
Sun and I love how they just have all
these delicious pastries just sitting
around oh look at that powdered sugar
sugar looks like it's like freshly baked
ready to be eaten every day look at that
almond croissants
so I've been to Italy and I've been to
Paris probably over four times and this
is one of the closest restaurants in
America that I've seen that has that
feel that Vibe and those kind of like
tissues look at that yeah cannoli right
there chocolate Tarts fruit tarts
yeah even like this menu the
presentation like it's all like squiggly
cursive you notice the squiggly cursive
oh like the extra fancy like yeah it
just feels very European here yeah I
need to go inside like I know I haven't
been inside yet
[Applause]
oh did you even see the bakery inside
yet I literally just said it happened
but I thought you have wandering eyes
like me because I collect this
you don't do that
um
oh yeah oh look at the line it's packed
out the wazuna there's more and more
people what's that [ __ ] bird yeah
foreign
I like to have like really like
specialty type dishes like even like on
the sweet side right we got Belgian
waffle and they got look at the sweet
side you know that really yeah because I
just was like I wanted to keep it as
like healthy
but so I kept it I kept it healthy too
right we got the American sirloin steak
and eggs served with pancakes you didn't
talk about my packages I did it but
every time why because you want pancakes
yeah because every time I see pancakes
my eyes always wander I always go okay
pancakes down to the pancakes see what
they got classic buttermilk okay that's
American I didn't know they had I didn't
even look did you even did you get that
one guy just for me but let's we'll
split it
you'll be kidding me what's the other
one s'mores Nutella banana oh guess who
got that one of course
yeah so yeah all the stuff I love just
the um just like classic brioche Berry
lemon curd I like how it's like a very
classic
um variation yeah like a very European
variation and then a crazy one oh right
here oh my
look there's marshmallows too oh my
goodness all right look at this
presentation yes it's the healthy
version so it's never super appealing
but still we got egg whites some greens
some Hollandaise sauce on the side and
oh babe you have to try this latte that
I found it's their house special one
just try it I mean what's different I
don't know oh let's try it Jesus
it's honey cinnamon it's the one that I
just showed you guys is it melted
marshmallow yep
what's your water
the dangers of eating with the kid that
presentation is elegant for you
you will you will you will
stressing out
okay so this latte is outstanding
don't touch Steve okay all the flavors
that they have here very subtle but it's
very impressive so you taste it and it
just tastes special it tastes high
quality yeah very very good
the marshmallows straight into the mouth
this is his happy happy breakfast
I just thought I knew it was gonna like
it you like it can Papa have some
Nutella a little bit of marshmallow
[Music]
that's really good
what is the chef chef
yeah get a little bit like everything a
little bit and then dip it in a little
sauce it's a little bit of sauce I don't
want it in the sauce you have to I don't
want it in the sauce it's the European
style
[Applause]
really right because it's like it's very
like European high quality tasting I
love it yeah I just always get scared
that I'm not gonna like the sauce so I'd
rather eat the raw ingredients oh I
always go I always go first what does
the chef intend and then I do my own
after yeah I'm not a daredevil
that looks so good
what is that is that butter I think it
is butter
is it butter it might be butter try it
[Applause]
thank you
it might be better you crazy bones
so now we're at Lake Las Vegas which is
about 30 35 minutes away from this trip
and it's like this secluded Lake area in
Vegas that not that many people know
about and they got paddle boards you can
rent big old boat and just a big old
Lake and they actually build houses all
the way around it which is really cool
out there you actually see some people
paddle boarding
having a good old time
I don't know how clean this water is
because it looks green
but it is it's supposed to be blue
good job I'm gonna drop you in there
do you think I'm gonna throw you in
there or no yeah what if I throw a mama
in there
why you hold on to me as you're pushing
me because I love you you big dummy I'm
not gonna let you fall in there
yeah
I feel like this guy secretly wants me
to push him in there I do too he loves
the party no no no don't throw anything
in the water you always want to throw
stuff in the water I'm gonna throw you
in the water here
does that make you scared yes you know
it's like a little snake
it's a big snake
hey mama can I tell you something yeah
I'm actually uh a little bit
disappointed why because uh I thought
there's gonna be way more like Cafe type
places like where we just ate at I
haven't walked around
but I could just tell that it pretty
much ends right there
and right there
I know boss that was gonna be way more
shops like uh like up here but nobody
knows about this place so there's not
that much stuff
I mean let's just keep walking around
okay what time is it
it's 12. it should already be yeah it
should be popping right really because
there's all I see is a grocery store
right there there is like a Panini Cafe
right there and then I think that's it
and it's just surrounded by like hotels
and resorts
and I thought there was gonna be like
way more little knick knack shops and
stuff
but I guess not that view is pretty cool
though where it goes all into the
Horizon then you got a mountain over
there
yeah monkey
s
yeah let's go I'm not where the grass is
no you need a wristband it says
okay this is pretty CUNY you hear the
music
and it is a little cafe over here
it's called Mimi and Coco Bistro and you
got a nice little view of the uh I was
gonna say ocean but Lake yes
hey you used your hands I thought you're
gonna jump without using your hands
whoa oh
it's really good
you did look at that Mama I think that's
like a half pipe or a quarter pipe
people probably hit it with jet skis and
go crazy
yeah I could do little flippy flips
I want to let go and go in the water you
want to go in the water so bad huh
okay I think I spoke too soon because
there's way more stuff over here there's
even a place called Tokyo Social House
what do you mean uh how did you know
because we literally had just like
parked and we're like there's nothing it
looked well it just looked like it ended
right there and there and did you just
say gelato
where
oh my goodness
are we going in there I mean I would
still like to keep walking okay let's
follow the Blondie
I always forget that you know what that
you're blonde yeah come on baby
that you fell no way I never fought
ever only fall in love for you okay so
there's actually a lot so over here you
have an Italian restaurant you even have
a casino back there and it seems like
it's the golf cart life where people
just bring their golf carts and ride and
bike life which is pretty cool so it's a
nice little like Village
CUNY area
that for some reason like I didn't even
look around the bend but as soon as I
looked around the bend it opened up to
so much more stuff which is very very
cool
how do you even know there's ice cream
who said ice cream
oh my goodness so that's why logos work
huh because we were using the code word
gelato
and somehow use you knew ice cream
all right so we're discovering more and
more so we just walked up here there's a
little Bike Shop nail salon hair salon a
cool coffee and tea spot over here that
was a casino that I pointed out earlier
a little Pub and then you make a right
and you go down here what are you
waiting for me mister
oh this is a restroom Oh I thought
there's more stuff going on here okay
what water fountain
this guy loves water there's no water in
the water fountain
hey that's a beefy golf cart
okay Mama
yeah I think I lost taika
finally
ah what do you want to do I'll go get
ice cream now oh let's go get ice cream
okay let's go so
there he is
excuse me he was hiding in there for a
long time
was it hot in there
really good that's good commitment
that's yucky water right there yeah yeah
look how green that is
now this is cool the Speakeasy Libations
gambling and tobacco
this is pretty cool and I just love how
everyone just brings their golf carts
that they had on the communities and
they just park it and hang
where did they go oh there he is
so this is the map of the whole joint
you're at the parking garage for the
hotel right here super nice looking
you got a question what's the question
yeah I'm gonna go there a little bit
okay I'm just showing everybody the map
what is that
it's a purple line it's graphic design
yeah it's a PSD file well look at that
man
where
yep men are funny
anyways so yeah this is where we're here
and we walk through all the little shops
so it goes in a big circle like that and
you can drive in from uh Henderson this
is on the Henderson side of Vegas and
then you got the nice Lake and that's
what it looks like right there got this
nice green grass area if you want to
just chill
and you can uh actually no there's a
sign that says you're not allowed to
chill no you cannot chill here but you
can enjoy this view which is beautiful
so here's a real estate company with
some pricing of the properties in this
area
if you want to get like waterfronts
ten thousand square foot a lot well
that's pretty big that's 1.4 million
over here
you can get new construction townhome
for 539 look at that wow that looks
really nice
over here oh next to a golf course
for eight hundred thousand
oh cool bedroom condo 289
000 so they got a wide range of homes
that you can get that's 1.25 million
this was 600 000.
this one definitely has the best of you
but it's also the most expensive pretty
cool if you guys want to live in Lake
Las Vegas
are you eating the giant ice cream
excuse me
let's get some ice cream
I know it's got a true cranial
troublemaker
someone looks like a happy camper
excuse me the biggest smile in the world
which one's this one the watermelon
oh thank you you're welcome and which
was this one strawberry
we'll go more
thank you
the strawberry is really good by then
we'll go with the watermelon that makes
logical sense yeah
okay because Bart won't do it but check
out how cute the decor is everything is
purple super monochromatic purple
cute little purple wall purple walls
like everything is so cute so purple
I love it my older sister's favorite
color is purple she would die in here
look at this
so cute
look at that everything is so cute and
purple
it's the sharing continues
just enjoying look at the lakeside views
if you've been to Italy this is
literally what it'll look like what part
of Italy was that Florence yes Florence
I remember taking a picture and these
things but instead of it being a hotel
like that there's just a bunch of
different shops so you'll have like
jewelry shops and you'll have like arts
and crafts and just a ton just all
across like calf cafes but bars so it's
really cool to see that here and it's
one of those if you know you know
foreign
[Applause]
but his attitude's still pretty big
Papa
let's take a picture